welcome back to law and crime daily our
last segment takes us to Los Angeles
where a jury is deadlocked in a rape
trial of actor Danny Masterson
the former That 70s Show starred faces
accusations from three women all former
members of the Church of Scientology who
practice alongside Masterson all three
testified during trial claiming their
assaults took place at Masterson's
Hollywood Hills Home prosecutors argue
that the religious groups of power and
influence prevented the victims from
speaking out sooner Masterson did not
take the stand but his defense team
argued The Acts were consensual and the
accusers stories were inconsistent the
defense also criticized Scientology
being Center Stage it was mentioned more
than 700 times during the trial the
judge declined a mistrial based on the
jury's indecision and says the jury has
to continue deliberations after the
Thanksgiving holiday
we're not at Deadlocks before the
Thanksgiving before Thanksgiving sorry
could this create more problems down the
road what if jurors start talking about
scientology and Masterson over uh
football and sweet potatoes during
Thanksgiving
absolutely Brian this long break
especially we're talking about over a
week where this jury's not going to be
sat inside of a courtroom deliberating
the problems that you can encounter is
number one jury tampering where someone
can tamper with a jury in these jurors
also that during Thanksgiving family
members are asking questions of the
jurors and also they can be watching the
news or researching things there's so
many things that can happen during a
huge break that it can actually cause a
mistrial and that's what people are
hoping not happen but either way Brian I
think it's going to be a mistrial anyway
because I don't think these 12 jurors
are going to be able to reach a
unanimous decision all right we'll see
how that goes but Terry I know it's
reading tea leaves but in a case like
this would you think uh who do you think
should be more confident in their case
till should it be the defense or the
prosecution
well it is like reading tea leaves but
if I had to do that I would say the
defense I would say Masters and this is
going to work to his benefit like
Bernardo said these jurors are home
they're thinking about Thanksgiving
they're talking to their family and if
in fact it turns out that some of them
did or they even worse watched on
television and saw some updates there
could be a mistrial and a mistrial would
definitely benefit Masterson prosecutors
at the end of the day if there is a
mistrial may decide they don't want to
bring charges again and part of the
problem is these women are going to have
to get back on the stand and the
prosecutors will keep that in the back
of their mind here's the other issue
with being out for so long some of those
doers probably don't even remember what
happened during the trial after a long
break so they're going to have to redo
some of the evidence and even though
they were deadlocked before it might be
more complicated because they're
re-listening to some of the evidence so
it's going to help Masterson at the end
of the day yeah it'd be interesting the
jurors dig their heels in or do they
switch sides we'll we'll see how this
comes about but thank